[Música]
una delegación del Estado colombiano y
otra de la guerrilla del eln reunidas en
Venezuela anunciaron que tras la primera
semana de noviembre reanudarán los
diálogos de paz las conversaciones
estarán auspiciadas por Venezuela Cuba y
Noruega tenemos análisis en esta emisión
Este martes el senado ruso aprobó por
unanimidad las leyes que ratifican los
tratados de anexión a Rusia de las
regiones de doniesc lugansk gerson y
saporiya solo falta la firma del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin para
finalizar el proceso de integración
unilateral
en Francia París y Marsella entre otras
ciudades anuncian el boicot al Mundial
de fútbol de Qatar una protesta contra
la violación de Derechos Humanos en el
país anfitrión de la copa del mundo y en
rechazo al impacto ambiental del evento
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
de nuestra región porque una delegación
del Estado colombiano y otra de la
guerrilla del eln reunidas en Venezuela
anunciaron que retomarán los diálogos de
paz después de la primera semana de
noviembre ambas partes acordaron volver
a las mesas de diálogo en un proceso
auspiciado por Venezuela Cuba y Noruega
recordemos que las conversaciones de paz
entre el gobierno de Bogotá y la
guerrilla fueron congeladas bajo la
presidencia de Iván Duque y ahora
reiniciar este proceso es el primer paso
hacia la paz total a la que aspira el
presidente Gustavo Petro conectamos
ahora con Néstor rosanía director
ejecutivo del centro de estudios en
seguridad y paz de Colombia Néstor
Buenas tardes empecemos analizando el
anuncio Qué importancia ha tenido
Venezuela en este de acuerdo y Qué
importancia tiene que junto con cubanor
y Noruega sea uno de los países garantes
del proceso
es muy importante la participación de
Venezuela no solo en este momento sino
históricamente varios procesos de paz en
Colombia se han intentado liderar o más
bien tener el apoyo digamos desde
Venezuela Entonces en este momento es
vital hay dos clases de países hay unos
países garantes y unos países
observadores el garante es el que va a
dar la mesa temática la metodología y la
logística en el proceso de paz con las
Farc fue Noruega y Cuba y los países
observadores son países acompañante a
cada una de las delegaciones muy
seguramente Venezuela será el país
observador que Acompaña a la delegación
del Ln y el estado colombiano acoger a
otro país para que también lo acompañen
el proceso de paz fue chile pero aquí Lo
importante es que se ha avanzado y que
por primera vez después de más de cinco
años nuevamente vemos al equipo
negociador de un gobierno de Colombia ya
prestó para comenzar estos diálogos con
y precisamente Qué diferencias se puede
esperar en este proceso entre el Ln y el
gobierno Petro Respecto a los diálogos
con los gobiernos pre de Colombia como
el de Juan Manuel Santos o el de Iván
Duque
Bueno lo primero importante es que ya
hay una metodología que se avanzó en el
gobierno de Santos ya hay unos puntos
que se limitaron en el gobierno de
Santos y ya hay un camino que se ha
avanzado no vamos a arrancar de Cero y
eso va a ahorrar mucho tiempo en la
negociación lo segundo en el lln sabe
que es estratégico llegar a un acuerdo
En este gobierno Un gobierno de
izquierda que puede ser más fácil llegar
a lo que tenía en gobiernos anteriores o
más de 20 años que estuvo el uribismo en
el poder y lo tercero es que también ya
hay un espacio político que abrieron las
FARC que se que saben que pueden llegar
a ser política y que ya tienen como unas
lecciones aprendidas de lo que fue el
proceso de paz con las Farc entonces
tienen varios elementos varias certezas
y claridades que antes no existían y
precisamente hacía referencia al acuerdo
con las Farc en el caso del eln qué
líneas principales Podría tener un
eventual acuerdo
bueno tener temas estratégicos el tema
de víctimas y y todo digamos lo que es
la reparación integral a las víctimas y
la justicia transicional eso ya está hay
una estructura con las Farc que viene
funcionando que la justicia especial
para la paz Entonces el Ln sabe que se
va a [__] a un modelo un modelo que ya
está funcionando lo segundo el tema de
participación política las Far tiene
algunos reparos pero en términos
generales ellos han participado han ido
a candidaturas etcétera entonces el Ln
también se podría [__] a esto y lo
tercero en términos de implementación de
los acuerdos hay vacíos hay cosas por
mejorar pero ya hay un modelo que se ha
implementado entonces bajo esas tres
dinámicas se le leen y ya se puede subir
a cosas ciertas ahora qué va a ser nuevo
en esta negociación con el Ln primero
que le lee ni quiere que haya un
replanteamiento del modelo minero
energético en Colombia eso va a ser muy
difícil así uno de los puntos de quiebre
lo segundo que haya una participación
masiva de la sociedad colombiana eso
tampoco ha sido claro cómo va a ser y
esos van a ser Digamos como esos dos
puntos difíciles de tratar en una mesa
negociación
néstornilla Seguiremos muy pendientes de
este proceso Muchas gracias por su
tiempo y por su análisis
gracias
nosotros cambiamos de información vamos
con información relacionada ahora con la
guerra en Ucrania porque este martes el
senado ruso aprobó por unanimidad la
anexión de donesk lugansk gerson y
saporiya a la federación rusa a la
espera de la firma del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin que supondría el punto y
final a este proceso unilateral el
conflicto sigue escalando sobre el
terreno por otro lado el kremlin informó
que 200.000 hombres se han alistado al
ejército en el marco de la movilización
parcial obligatoria y kiev reivindica
nuevos avances en el sur y en el este
del país
la decisión se ha tomado por unanimidad
tal como ocurrió en la víspera en la
duma Este martes los miembros del senado
ratificaron la incorporación de las
autoproclamadas republicas de doniach y
logans y las provincias de gersoni
zaporitia como parte de la federación
rusa los territorios anexados
unilateralmente por el kremlin suponen
cerca del 18% del territorio reconocido
emocionalmente a Ucrania en paralelo
Moscú sigue entrenando a miles de
soldados para llevarlos al frente de
batalla tras su llamado a la
movilización parcial de hace dos semanas
al día de hoy más de 200.000 personas se
han incorporado a las fuerzas armadas he
ordenado que se les proporcione a todos
ellos uniformes y otros equipos
necesarios y se les nombre en puestos
militares el personal de servicio debe
ser enviada a las zonas de combate
después del fin del entrenamiento y el
ensayo
en el terreno la arremetida continúa
desde Ucrania temen que los ataques del
ejército ruso contra infraestructuras
estratégicas puedan redoblarse con la
llegada del Invierno no obstante en kiev
siguen reivindicando sus avances en el
sur y el oeste liberando según las
autoridades varias localidades a las
orillas del río nipro Los logros
militares los reflejan estos soldados
ucranianos izando banderas en pueblos de
jarqui y gerson
hay nuevos asentamientos liberados en
varias regiones continúan los combates
feroces en muchas áreas del frente pero
la perspectiva de estas hostilidades
sigue siendo obvia cada vez más
ocupantes están tratando de escapar el
ejército enemigo está sufriendo más y
más bajas y hay una comprensión
creciente de que Rusia cometió un error
al ir a la guerra contra Ucrania pese a
los llamados de nuevas sanciones
internacionales
Moscú sigue escalando su ofensiva dentro
y fuera de Ucrania
y cambiamos de nuevo de información
porque igual que hizo ayer el líder
supremo de Irán el ayatolá alija meneid
hoy el presidente iraní Ibrahim Racing
acusó a Estados Unidos y a Israel de
organizar las protestas por la muerte de
maxa Amin recordemos que la joven murió
tras ser detenida por la policía de la
moral y que fue el mismo día de su
funeral el 17 de septiembre cuando se
desató el movimiento contra la represión
y la brutalidad del régimen de Teherán
Rey sí pidió unidad nacional mientras
las protestas se extienden por los
centros educativos del país escuchemos
las palabras del presidente iraní
porque los enemigos porque Estados
Unidos y el régimensionista conspiraron
contra nuestra nación nuestro país y
nuestra Revolución y crearon estos
disturbios como dijo el líder supremo
nuestro país Está avanzando y los
enemigos no quieren que nuestro país
progresen
y en otras noticias Corea del Norte
disparó un misil balístico sobre Japón
por primera vez en cinco años como
respuesta Tokio activo su sistema de
alerta antimisiles y emitió una inusual
advertencia para que la población
buscará Refugio iba era una mañana
normal en Japón hasta que ocurrió esto
tenemos noticias de última hora el
gobierno japonés advierte que Corea del
Norte parece haber lanzado al menos un
misil balístico existe la posibilidad de
que se dirija a Japón el gobierno está
llamando a todos en el país a permanecer
en el interior o encontrar un refugio
inmediatamente
en todo Japón en pequeños pueblos y
grandes ciudades sonaron las sirenas
junto con un mensaje ominoso
[Música]
un misil ha sido lanzado Corea del Norte
parece haber lanzado un misil
mensajes de advertencia llegaron a los
teléfonos los trenes de alta velocidad
se detuvieron abruptamente con el mismo
mensaje repetido en bucle
[Música]
se dio el visto bueno unos 20 minutos
después el misil cayó en el Pacífico
pero el daño estaba hecho el país estaba
sacudido y enfadado
vivo en un apartamento Así que no tengo
sótano cuando me dijeron que me pusiera
cubierto bajo tierra mi reacción sincera
fue realmente no sé qué hacer aunque no
haya sanciones quiero que el gobierno
adopte una postura más firme frente a
Corea del Norte
me sentía asustada si su tecnología ha
mejorado significa que están trabajando
en ello a diario Me preocupa que algún
día puedan fabricar un misil potente
fue la primera vez que un misil
norcoreano sobrevoló Japón desde 2017
las autoridades calificaron en el
disparo como un acto imprudente y
dijeron que la distancia de vuelo
estimada de este misil en particular Era
la más larga entre los cohetes lanzados
anteriormente
y cerramos en Francia porque París ha
decidido unirse a otras ciudades
francesas para boicotear el mundial de
Qatar de fútbol el boicot es una
protesta contra la violación de derechos
humanos y el desmedido y negativo
impacto medioambiental que ha supuesto
la organización de este evento en Qatar
pero la medida no está exenta de
polémica
la Euforia colectiva la atención de
animar a su selección en medio de una
multitud de personas las zonas de
aficionados son sinónimo del mundial
Pero esta vez en muchas ciudades
francesas dicen que no habrá pantallas
gigantes ni concentraciones masivas las
razones para el boicot son muchas hubo
un aumento de las protestas
especialmente después de que un artículo
de 2021 publicado en el diario de
Guardian afirmará que más de 6.500
trabajadores inmigrantes habían perdido
la vida en la construcción de los
estadios de Qatar Además del historial
medio Oriental negativo del país que
acoge el mundial y del coste energético
de las zonas de aficionados o sea
estos acontecimientos estarían en total
conflicto con la sobriedad energética
que exigimos a nuestros ciudadanos
estadios en el desierto para muchas
ciudades francesas la ubicación de la
Copa no tiene sentido desde el punto de
vista medioambiental la alcaldesa de
lille escribió en Twitter que su ciudad
no verá ni un solo partido por el coste
para el medio ambiente y las denuncias
de violaciones a los derechos humanos en
Qatar pero es esto
suficientemente horrible no solo hay que
boicotear el mundial entonces hay que
cortarle el paso no venderle más aviones
o jets ni comprarle petróleo siempre lo
paso mal cuando solo se boicotean los
deportes
Aunque algunos lo consideran un paso
positivo otros han criticado los boicots
por considerarlos hipócritas citando a
París como ejemplo boicotea la copa pero
también ha fomentado la inversión de
Qatar en la capital y hasta ahora no ha
dudado en animar al equipo París
saint-germain de propiedad
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24.com
[Música]